if you want to lead something start by
saying this is what i care about this is
what i want to do and why i think you
should care about it and you should want
to help
[Music]
hardly a day goes by that i don't think
how fast my life has flown how i
remember as it were yesterday the first
day i became president
[Music]
hardly anything worth doing can be done
alone this is a particularly
disorienting time for billions of people
in the world you've got major
uncertainties about what's going to
happen in the years ahead
at a time like that you really need good
leadership skills and you need people
whose goal it is to pull people together
not drive them apart people need to feel
the potential to create a better
tomorrow
this class is unlike anything i've ever
done i'll be teaching skills i developed
and used in very challenging leadership
positions and i hope that those skills
will help you in your personal and
professional lives
you'll learn how to work with people you
don't agree with
and may not even like and how to mediate
conflicts i don't believe being nice is
inconsistent with being tough and smart
you got to be tough as nails with your
tender heart
i have encountered a lot of setbacks i
lost two elections after i entered
politics i've had ferocious opposition
where the whole strategy was to try to
destroy me as a person my mother died
after i became president i've had a lot
of things that really hurt
but in the end the great adventure of
life is what you decide to do with it
we're all struggling mortals with
fleeting lives who are trying to be
right as often as we can and trying to
live a life that amounts to something
a good leader will share the credit when
something good happens and assume
responsibility for the mistakes and not
look for a scapegoat i believe leaders
are not just born they are also made and
i hope everybody who watches this will
say what am i going to do to be a better
leader
[Music]
i'm president bill clinton and this
is masterclass
[Music]
you